how's um presents welcome to the scary
escape the series where we're trying to
find the scariest game ever as if
watching a man with big headphones and
pink sweater it's not scary enough we're
gonna start off with safety blanket I
don't know if this game is actually
scary
just kidding I'm actually terrified look
at that face oh no they're coming Oh
who's sleeps like this Oh God
gotta protect my limbs the night creeps
ruin your sleep at 11:46 look at poor
fates if the tentacles reach you it's
game over
well that's not what I hear in Japan
stop [ __ ] moving that'd be great
oh okay I used to blanket defend off the
tentacles stop the hentai they should
name this game spooky scary tentacles
come scribbling up your head go away
tentacles
you can't have my sexy body oh my god
that is terrifying cover that bold son
of a [ __ ]
yeah damn tentacles stop coming at me
stop No 5:19 hey that was pretty good
Slenderman must I keep dead space do you
change your name now what the [ __ ]
what do we got here some sandwiches yes
that would be nice
Oh a bread gun my favourite kind of gun
alrightlet's studious radioactive every
game I started up every game all right
this bread gun is quite amazing I can't
wait for the future when everyone has
one I'm running it 360 noscopes Enderman
so hard
oh that [ __ ] are you what are you doing
don't [ __ ] this oh my god oh my god oh
god it is slender and he brought head
tentacle porn with him alright I kill
him now on five nights at various all
right another five nights of Freddie
clone
five night at [ __ ] boys - where's number
one hey I move em Freddie a with a
streamer appeared engaged it's like hey
we kill this dreamer [ __ ] that stream
all right yes like during these videos
my hair just progresses into its taking
its own form so what it's called the
plague the great blog of Landon whoa
it's so dark I need my candle out judge
what is going on here hello - good job
good job
no indigent ja nein what'd I tell you
about cheating yeah idea made goon cha
that sexy son of a [ __ ] cannot have his
hands of other men I have to get out of
here but I am out what am i doing I've
collected pumpkins yay a thousand I'm
not gonna collect a thousand pumpkins
all right just get that far the arrow
tells me this way so [ __ ] it
[Music]
sleep right emoji joke's on you my name
is [ __ ] pie total pumpkins collected 37
you do not have to collect all the
pumpkins
well no [ __ ] [ __ ] now I have to
collect 1200 pumpkins how the hell would
anyone carry that many pumpkins why
would you need that many pumpkins they
said there was a sign by the huge tree
god
gosh darnit hell even though it was some
fun oh that the [ __ ] was that
you son of a licking [ __ ]
[Music]
you like pump easy path are we back at
the house we suck my ass then [ __ ] off
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
ha scary maze really think that's gonna
scare me
but there
my
you kill me
[Music]
that boy needs therapy